[Applause]
party B slays the AMAs from her stunning
red carpet floral ensemble alongside her
hubby offset to her first award show
performance since becoming a mom to her
baby girl culture the boudic yellow
singer was the star of the show
although cardi took home two American
Music Awards out of her eight
nominations including best rap hip-hop
artist thank you Jesus she delivered an
iconic acceptance speech in true cardi
fashions I really want to thank my
daughter cuz they said I wasn't gonna
make it at the head up
my husband cosmic during the show
cardies music video for her hot fire
track talkie-talkie dropped which
features Selena Gomez and Ozuna Taylor
Swift posed for a photo with the rap
superstar making fans hopeful of a
future collab and the audience seemed to
be in full support of cardi as they were
dancing along and gave a standing
ovation after her epic I like it
performance he caught up with bad bunny
and J Balvin on the red carpet ahead of
the show where they had nothing but
praise for the 25 year old singer so
grateful to Bacardi B for the
opportunity you know my boy born in
Columbia Puerto Rico Wow you know first
of all it's our first time here so the
fact that we're doing a song that we did
in Spanish it's everything you know it's
basically - one of the main crossover
without singing English
[Music]